- I knew that at some point
he had to admit that
he was going to use it.
But I said, "Why not now?"
And he said, "It's
not ready yet.
This isn't the time yet."
So I think what he
is preparing for
is something really
big on election night.
(soft serene music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report".
Quick reminder everybody
to subscribe to our
YouTube channel,
so you actually get
notified of our new videos.
And joining me today is a
former New York State prosecutor
and judge: host of "Justice
with Judge Jeanine" on Fox News
and author of the new book
"Don't Lie to Me: And Stop
Trying to Steal Our Freedom".
Judge Jeanine Pirro, welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Well it's a pleasure
to be with you
and on the other end actually.
And I really appreciate
you plugging my book
right off the bat.
In fact, I have it
right here behind me
right under "Don't
Burn This Book".
So it as you could see you
know, it's a 50/50 here.
People will decide
your book or my book.
Probably your book.
- No, no, no, no, no.
This is gonna be
all about your book
and I have to tell people
a couple insider things
before we fully start here.
Because although we have
not met in real life yet
because of this
COVID ridiculousness,
I've been doin'
your show a bunch
and I feel like we
have this kinship
even though we haven't actually
broken bread yet or anything.
And one of the things
that strikes me about you
is I do a lotta the Fox shows
and on no other show does the
host call the guest before,
but you call me when
I'm usually on Saturdays
when you're live.
You call me in the afternoon,
you ask how I'm doin'
and then you always say,
"And what's on your mind?
What are you thinkin' about?
What's goin' on?"
And that strikes me
as just very different
than how all of
cable news is done
that you're just
really interested
in talking about what
people really care about.
Is that fair to
say, Judge Jeanine?
How is that for
a first question?
- Well first of all,
it was very informative
because I have no idea
how the other people
do their shows on Fox.
But what I can tell you is
maybe it's my background
that speaks to who I am.
I am a little different
from those people on Fox.
I mean I've been a
prosecutor, a judge and a DA.
For 32 years, I ran
for office five times.
I mean I have a
different background
and a different skillset.
And to this day,
I'll say I need a good
witness for this one.
And you know, it's not a
witness it's against obviously.
But I really think
it's important that
people come on a show
and talk about what's
important to them.
And as long as we
have an intersection
where it's important to me and
I believe then to the public
that that's your
passion, you know?
That's what you're
interested in,
then you literally
jump off the screen.
Because to me,
passion is everything.
And I've long believed
and I tried jury trials.
I was a litigator for many
years and it's what moves me.
It's what moves people.
So I didn't know any of that
or that other people
didn't do that,
but I always like to get a sense
of what you wanna talk about
and where your head is.
I don't rely on other
people to screen my guests.
That's not what I do.
- Yeah.
Do you like doin' the TV stuff
more than bein' a prosecutor
or bein' a judge or do you
just think it's exercising
like a different skillset
or somethin' like that?
- Well you gave me a
great outright there,
exercising a different skillset.
But the truth is the
best job in the world
was being a prosecutor, Dave.
I mean without a doubt
and I'll tell you why.
I don't mean a prosecutor
in the sense that you know,
you're out there and you
know, lockin' people up.
No, being a prosecutor to me
was about making
victims whole again.
It leads to the
extent that you can.
It might even be just
the victim's families.
But you know, when I first
started prosecuting crimes,
I became an assistant DA in 1975
which you know, my
kids will tell you
that's when they wrote
the laws on stone tablets
and stopped counting my age.
I see your eyes. (vocalizes)
And it was like the
victims were nothing more
than an element of the case,
the people of the State of
New York against John Smith,
all right?
But to me, the victim was
the reason we were there.
The victim was the person who
never chose to be a victim,
who never chose to be the
system in the first place.
And so my energies were trying
to make that victim whole again,
whether the victim was a five
year old who had been raped
and didn't know the language
you know, just said "Peachy pie.
My honey bun."
And teaching them with
anatomically-correct dolls,
how they could
communicate with a jury
or a senior citizen who ended
up losing you know, her house
because she was a victim
of economic crimes.
So that to me was my passion
and I did it for many decades.
I went to the bench.
Because to be a judge you know,
it's supposed to be the
citadel or the practice of law.
Hogwash, it's not.
I felt like a referee.
I felt that when I was a
judge sitting on the bench
you know, I would
sustain an objection,
overrule an objection.
They'd come up to
me and they'd argue
and I wanted to be in the fight.
You know, it's not
really my personality.
So I had a tenure term
and after three years,
I said I've had enough of
this and I ran for judge.
I was the first woman
judge in the history,
a county judge in the
history of the county.
And I said, "I can't
take this anymore.
This is too slow for me."
And I remember that
I spoke to the chief
administrative judge.
And I said, "You know, judge?
While I'm taking a plea
with one defendant,
if you could have
the court officers
bring another defendant
outta the bullpen,
his lawyer can talk to him.
And then as soon as
this plea is over,
he's ready to plea or
whatever the motion could be."
And I thought I was
so sharp, right?
And I'd move things along.
I said, "I could handle
twice the cases."
And his response was, "Are
you tryin' to make the men
look bad, Jeanine?"
(Dave chuckling)
And you know, I didn't
take it personally.
But I thought to myself
whether this is sexist
or not, doesn't matter.
This is not the
speed that I work at.
So I stepped off the bench and
I ran for district attorney
because I was a fighter.
I started the first domestic
violence unit in the country.
You know, first hate crimes unit
in the history of my
county, sex crimes unit
and worked with you know,
John Cardinal O'Connor
in trying to make sure
that everyone was covered
under hate crimes.
It wasn't just you know,
gender and ethnicity and color
but sexual orientation as well.
And as president of
the DA's Association,
John Cardinal O'Connor who
was beloved in New York,
went in and supported that
and it became part
of New York law.
So where I saw problems,
I was able to move
the legislature.
If I had enough
support believe me,
I don't think
singularly I could.
But I could do something to
try to make a difference.
Where I saw victimization,
I would go out there
and publicly say
with the advent of the
internet, your kids cannot use
the PC as a babysitter.
And I started the first internet
pedophile sting operation
in the nation and we arrested
doctors, lawyers, priests,
coaches, school superintendents,
CEOs, you name it.
And it was very
satisfying for me.
But I gave that job update
because I felt that
I had done it enough
and it was kind of like my
own self-imposed term limits.
But without a doubt, it was
the best job in the world.
- So what brought
you to cable news?
I mean as if you hadn't had
enough fights in the courtroom
and then runnin' for prosecutor
you know, all of this.
DA and all that, it's like what?
I mean there's no fight
like a cable news fight.
- Well I must tell you
that for whatever reason
I got involved in television
and it was the OJ Simpson case.
I believe it was 1994
and that Bronco chase.
And I remember I had
just become the DA
and I had you know, all 150
assistant DAs at my home.
And one of the guys came out,
I think it was one
of the investigators.
He said, "Hey boss, you're
not gonna believe it.
OJ Simpson's in a Bronco.
They're chasin' him."
I said, "What are
they chasing him for?
Is he speeding?"
Nobody knew.
But that was really the advent
of you know, my introduction
into the importance of
the media in identifying
and trying to you know,
change certain issues
in our society.
So for battered women you know,
I started the first
unit in the nation
under the Department of Justice.
And people kept
thinking battered women.
Sex is better for them
after their beaten
or they deserved it or you
know, "She's a pain in the ass."
And you know, as a
woman assistant DA,
I had to deal with 43 male
police chiefs in my jurisdiction
and deal with that kind of...
There was a discrimination.
The thinking was marriage is
forever, be a better wife.
If he's beating you,
be a better wife.
Go pray.
And so we were part of a change.
It made a tremendous difference.
But I saw the
importance in the media.
And as a prosecutor, I
used the media to help me
identify issues and get more
victims to come forward.
- So just hearing your
history a little bit
and some of this stuff
I actually didn't know,
does it drive you
crazy when people say,
"Oh, conservatives
are anti-women,"
or "Conservatives are anti-gay,"
or "Conservatives are racist"?
Or the rest of it.
We've talked a little bit
about that on your show.
But when you hear
some of the things
that you've been involved in,
it's kinda crazy that people
get these labels on 'em.
- And you know, the movie that
they made about Roger Ailes
and the women of Fox
who had all these issues
and for any victim.
Anyone is truly a victim.
Remember as a prosecutor,
I had to decide is it real?
Is it credible?
Is it believable?
Does it make sense?
You know, my heart
goes out to them
and my passion went out to
them along with my energy.
But in the movie that they
made and I never saw it,
they portrayed me as someone
who was, as I understand it,
apologetic for you
know, the offenders.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And it made me crazy, Dave.
It made me nuts.
I said to myself for
all those #MeToo women,
where the hell were you in
the late 70s and the early 80s
when I was fighting for
children to testify?
Where the hell were you when I
was trying to make it illegal
to put women on a
lie detector test
to claim that they were raped?
Where were you
when I was fighting
to make sure that women
couldn't be judged
because they wore a short skirt
which then allows a
defense attorney to say,
"You were askin' for it"?
You wear a Rolex.
If you're burglarized
Dave or someone robs you,
they're not gonna say,
"Hey, you wore that Rolex
'cause you want
it to be robbed."
But a woman wears a short skirt,
"She wore that skirt 'cause
she wanted to be raped."
You know, it makes me crazy
because I've spent
my life fighting
for the silent victims
of crime, for women,
for the elderly, for children.
People have no idea
what happens to children
in our system today.
You know, I started getting
reports of suspected child abuse
in the late 70s and
they said to me,
"You're not entitled to those."
I said, "Yes, I am."
I mean there's a certain
benefit to naivete.
In my moral core said,
"Bologna, of course you are."
And they said, "No,
these are privileged.
They stay with social services."
So I had an all-out war
and I was gonna sue the
Department of Social Services.
I went to the DA and he says,
"Oh, let little Jeanine.
Let her go do her
social things."
And it turned out,
I said to them,
"Look, if a social worker
goes and finds that a child
is maybe being abused
but returns the
child to the parents,
that record is then expunged.
And maybe if
they're called again
and they don't find anything,
that record is expunged.
But the third time
the kid is dead, okay?
I want the first record
and the second record
and don't you dare tell me
that I can't get a history
of abuse in a criminal case
when I've got the
homicide of that child."
And I did child abuse homicides,
that was one of my expertise.
Whether it's shaken
baby syndrome,
immersion in scalding water,
being beaten to death.
I mean I can tell you stories
that'd make your hair stand.
And I don't talk
about it often, Dave.
And I don't know, you just
kinda hit a thing in my head.
Very rarely do people
even know what I did
other than, "Oh she was the
DA, whatever that means."
But no, I have a passion
and I have an empathy
for the victim.
The victim was everything to me.
Why do we name the system, Dave?
Think about this.
The criminal justice system.
It should be the
victim justice system.
The victim never wanted
to be a part of this.
But all of a sudden
like a thunderbolt,
their lives are changed
and the ripple effect to their
family and the community,
it's enormous and you know,
what we're seeing today
is just an example of
all that craziness.
- So when you hear people
talk about systemic racism
that is in our criminal
justice system.
Well I guess first, do
you think that exists?
And if it does exist, can
you gimme an example of it
or a time that you
came up against it?
- I absolutely do not believe
there's systemic racism.
I think that the laws are
in place to protect everyone
and I watched those laws
evolve over the years.
But in terms of what I've done,
lemme be real clear about this.
Are there bad cops?
Yes, absolutely.
Have I prosecuted bad cops?
Did I like it?
I didn't really like
it or dislike it.
It was the only
way to handle it.
I prosecuted an off-duty
New York City police officer
for shooting an African American
over a parking space
in Westchester.
Dave, to this day,
that guy who was the cop.
I convicted him.
He was convicted.
My office convicted him.
He was convicted and he
went to prison for 25 years.
To this day, these guys are
after me for doing that.
Now I had no idea.
But Al Sharpton who I knew
'cause I ran for office
you know, so many times.
Al Sharpton wanted
to make a visit.
He called my secretary, at the
time there were secretaries
and she said, "Boss, Al
Sharpton wants to visit you
with a few reverends."
I said, "Why not?"
You know, that's fine.
So they came in one
morning after the verdict
about three or four days
and they brought in pastries
and we made coffee for them.
And you know, I sat and I
kinda waited for a second.
And they said, "We
wanna thank you."
And I said, "For what?"
And they said, "Never in
the history of New York
has a white cop been convicted
of killing a black man."
And I didn't realize
that it was historic.
Am I proud of it?
No, I'm not proud of it.
I'm not ashamed of it.
It was a horrible
thing that happened,
but it was the
right thing to do.
But to this day when the NYPD
gave me an award two years
ago, that guy's friends,
the white cop's friends
from New York City,
they're still after me.
I have a radio show WABC.
They call me up to say, "You're
this and that," you know?
And then I just go like that.
They get rid of the call.
But I've come across a lot
of cases that were ugly.
But if your moral
core is strong,
if you know who you are,
if you're not a weak
link, then it's easy.
You do what you have to do.
- So actually I wasn't
gonna ask you this,
but I think it's sorta
the perfect segue
before we get to the book.
So speakin' of moral core
in doin' what you think
is right and all that,
you're a New Yorker.
As you know, I'm
born-and-bred New Yorker
until I moved out to
Cali eight years ago,
so I've only lived in
New York and California.
What is it do you
think about New York?
Like you strike me
as such a New Yorker,
like in the best sense of
what New York is, you know?
People think if you're from New
York and Cali, you're crazy.
But I mean New York in just
sort of the ethnic makeup
of New York and the no BS and
call it as it is and all that.
Can you just tell me
a little bit about
just like your family makeup
and where some of
that came from?
- Okay, sure.
I'd be happy to.
I'm of Lebanese descent.
I don't know if
you even knew that.
Everyone assumes because
I married an Italian
and my name is Jeanine.
- Italian.
Yeah, I thought
you were a purebred
off-the-boat from Sicily.
- No, no.
I'm Lebanese Christian,
both my mom and dad.
My dad fought in World War II.
He was not first generation.
My grandfather fought
in World War II,
but I'm 100% Lebanese Christian.
We kept the subculture alive.
I cook the food.
I cook hummus, tabbouleh
and baba ganoush;
You know, the grape leaves.
I do all that stuff.
But I'm gonna surprise you.
I grew up in a small
town in upstate New York
and I worked in a
dairy as a young kid.
You know, people say to me,
"Are you from the Bronx?
Are you from (drowned
out by poor audio)?"
No, actually I'm from Elmira.
And they're like,
"Where is that?"
And in fact Dave for
the longest time,
I had potbelly pigs in my
yard here in Westchester.
You know, the pigs.
(imitates pig snorting)
Those pigs.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And one lived I
think it was 16 years.
I mean I just
liked farm animals.
You know, upstate New York
is more like middle America,
you know?
I learned how to shoot a gun.
Church was important.
Education was important.
I'm the first one in my
family to go to college.
And you know, it was a very
simple, very simple life.
Nothing complicated about it.
And my mom passed last year in
the room right above us here.
I had her in hospice.
You know, she was everything.
She gave me you know, the
moral compass to both empathize
and she gave me that
heart for victims.
You know, they just weren't
people that you prosecuted for.
They were your family.
And yet the tough side of me
came from being a prosecutor.
You know, I was the first woman
that went out on
a homicide review.
And you know, I
remember the first time
I went out on a homicide call.
I went out.
You know, like the first
thing I said you know, laugh.
The call comes in of course
at 3:00 in the morning.
Homicides only happen
So after they have an
argument with my then-husband
that he was gonna get his
wife and they kept saying,
"No, we want the assistant
DA," 'cause I was the first.
(chuckles) So yeah,
I say to my husband
after they tell me the location.
I say, "What do you
wear to a homicide?"
(laughs) So I'm like, "Oh god,
what a dumb thing to say."
He said, "It doesn't matter
what you wear, Jeanine.
Just take the penal
law along with you."
So when I got there, they didn't
wanna let me on the scene.
And I said, "No, no.
I'm really an assistant DA."
I was like 25 years old.
So yeah, it's been an
interesting career.
I'm very, very lucky
I had a simple life
to deal with this
complicated world.
- I'm pretty sure the
title of your next book is
"What Do Ya Wear to a Homicide?"
I think we got that right there.
Oh and by the way, for the
record I do know Elmira
because I went to
SUNY, Binghamton.
- No.
- So I know a little bit.
I know a little bit about
the southern tier, yeah.
- Oh my gosh, WENY?
- Yeah.
- Do you remember WENY?
- Of course I do.
- Did you ski?
- Not well, I could fall down
a mountain pretty decently.
- Yeah?
Oh my gosh.
Yeah. My grandfather lived
in Binghamton anyway.
- Yeah, all right.
So let's shift a
little bit here.
I know that this
interview right now
is obviously your biggest
interview of the week.
But a few days ago, you did
sit down with this other guy.
I'm sure some of my audience
has heard about him before.
This Donald Trump fella.
I'm sure some people
have heard of him.
Can you just tell
me a little bit
sorta like what
is the preparation
as an interviewer to do that?
I know you have a relationship
and you know, he calls in
and all that kinda stuff.
But like just what's it like
sittin' down with the guy
and try to just make sense of
the world with him right now?
- You know, as you said
I've known Donald Trump
for about 35 years.
My then-husband Al
who answered the phone
and fought with his
sergeant who kept saying,
"I'm not the assistant
DA, Jeanine is,"
represented Donald for years.
So we spend time, most weekends
going to Florida with Donald
when my kids were little
and his kids were little,
so I know the man.
I know Donald Trump, the man.
I have a sense of
you know, who he is
and I know a side of him,
not the caricature that
they make them out to be.
I know that he's brilliant.
But to answer your
question directly,
how do you sit down
and prepare for it?
First thing you do is
you figure out topics
what do you wanna
talk to him about?
The biggest issues right
now are the pandemic,
the rioting and the looting,
the election, the debate.
Joe Biden: is he capable?
And the things that no
one was talking about
that I thought was so important
were the Nobel Peace Prize.
I mean the Abraham
Accords just signed.
I mean talk about Israel,
the United Arab Emirates,
Israel and Bahrain.
I mean this is big stuff.
And you know, apparently the
Saudis are about to follow.
So I talked to him about that
and I write my questions out.
And you know, I've never
talked to anyone else at Fox
on how they do it.
It's almost like you're
trying a case, you know.
But it's your direct case,
it's not really a
cross-examination.
But you know that you're gonna
have to push a little bit.
So there are two
questions where I pushed.
One question was,
Look, I said something
like, "Mr. President,
I know that you have to be
invited into certain areas
in order to bring in
the National Guard
as you did in Milwaukee
and as you did in Kenosha.
But there are some places
they will just not have you in
and they'd rather see
rioting and looting.
The word is that
on election night
assuming that there's a winner.
And if you win, if
you are the winner
and there are the
promised riots,
looting and anarchy,
what will you do?"
He said, "We'll put
it down very quickly."
"What will you do?"
"We're gonna put it
down very quickly."
"What will you do?"
He said, "Insurrection."
He's gonna use the
Insurrection Act.
And you know, I knew
that at some point
he had to admit that
he was going to use it.
But I said, "Why not now?"
And he said, "It's
not ready yet.
This isn't the time yet."
So I think what he
is preparing for
is something really
big on election night.
Where were you on
election night?
Do you remember 2016?
- Yeah, I was on air on the
Daily Wire with Ben Shapiro
and the crew over there.
My one takeaway of the night.
I don't know if you
know Andrew Klavan
who's one of the hosts
on the Daily Wire.
He said something
that I thought was really
brilliant that night.
He said, "Only in America
could the thing that everyone
said couldn't happen,
could happen."
And I thought well all right,
whether you love
Trump or hate Trump,
the fact that something
like that can happen,
that all the pundits
could get it wrong,
all the pollsters
all the elites
could get it wrong.
That's actually pretty beautiful
that that goes to the strength
of our democracy actually.
- You know, and it really does
go to the strength
of our democracy
that it's not so predictable.
It's not so set in stone.
It's not as though people
are orchestrating it.
I remember coming out of the
Hilton on election morning.
It was like 3:30 or
4:00 in the morning
and I was just so excited.
I mean I think Buzzfeed, one
of 'em had a picture of me
standing on a chair
with a Trump hat on
and I had the loudest
dress I could wear.
It was like orange
flowers or something.
And so I'm like
dancin' outta the hotel
and all of a sudden somebody
starts cursin' at me.
And you know and I look
down and I look up,
the guy's like six four
and he's cursin' me out.
And you know, not
a shy New Yorker.
I went right back at him
who was taller than me.
Although he was in a tutu,
but he was really tall.
So the cop said to me,
"Judge, come over here."
I said, "No, make
him go over there."
You know, I'm really
stupid sometimes.
- [Dave] (chuckles)
You're a New Yorker.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Whatever the reason
is, I was stupid.
And so then they start.
Another guy started
coming out cursing,
"She's a Trump person."
So the reason I bring it up
is I guarantee you that 2020
if the president is announced
as the winner that night,
it's gonna be wild.
I truly believe he will win.
I think that even people, Dave,
in those towns where
there's anarchy
like Portland and Seattle.
And I know those
are liberal states,
like Oregon and all that.
But there are people
now who are afraid.
They're afraid.
They survived kinda the pandemic
and they have one shot to
get back their business
which is the security for their
family, which is their ego,
their sense of self,
their sense of self-worth.
Our jobs are who we are.
And (claps) bang, the protesters
come in and destroy it.
I don't think they want
the left controlling that
and getting away with impunity.
This is impunity.
But it's not one thing, Dave.
It's not like all of a sudden
it was a perfect storm that
George Floyd died
and you know, everybody said,
"All right, let's revolt."
No, you don't find bricks
in the middle of
a pandemic, right?
Nobody's building
anything in Manhattan.
And all of a sudden
all over the country,
there's no bail statutes.
So everyone who's being
arrested is being let out.
And even the ones who
are being arrested,
they've now got prosecutors
who have been elected
with the support of the
Democrat socialists of America
who are saying, "We're
not prosecuting them.
We're not putting
people in jail.
We're letting
people out of jail."
And so now this whole layer
that we haven't even noticed
is on fire and it is set
for a huge turnaround.
And this is the last chance
we have in this country
to secure law and order.
- All right, so that
brings us to the book
because I read a bunch
of it this morning.
And the opening of
the book in essence,
you say, "This is a
battle of good and evil."
And you know, I've sort
of come around to that.
Like I don't like thinking
that my ideological
enemies are evil
and I think a lot of them
have good intentions.
But I think in
effect at this point,
this thing that we're fighting
that you're talkin' about,
this Marxist revolution
and Antifa and BLM
and this whole thing,
it has become evil
even if some of them do
have good intentions.
Do you really believe that
this is sort of the last stand?
You know, we always say
this is the most
important election ever.
But do you really
feel like this is it,
like this is the final stand?
- You know, you're right.
We always say it.
People always say,
"This is the most important
election in your lifetime."
I really mean it this time.
I mean I would take
an oath on this.
You know, I would
go to church on this
because there's so much at stake
and we're right at the
precipice where it'll all fall.
I spent 32 years in law
enforcement in the courts
in the criminal justice system.
I know that.
That is my wheelhouse.
And what is happening now is
with the defunding of police,
with the stand-down police
orders, with the no bail,
with prosecutors who are
refusing to prosecute.
What we've got now
is total anarchy.
And when the left talks
about open borders,
locking you down,
defunding the police.
And when Kamala Harris says
the Constitution doesn't stop
her from taking away our guns,
we got real problems.
We've got real problems.
And you know what I think?
I think not just the people
who live in the cities
that have been destroyed:
Milwaukee, Kenosha which
is small-town America,
Milwaukee and Chicago
and Seattle and
Portland and Detroit.
Not Detroit so much,
they're in good shape.
But Washington and so many
cities, New York City.
I mean the Democrats
know what they need
and they need law enforcement.
They need criminal justice.
People in the inner city know
that the vast
majority of victims
of crime are
black-on-black crime, okay?
They know they need protection.
And so the black reverends,
the Hispanic pastors
and all that other
stuff, priests,
they want law enforcement
in the community.
But the criminals
are now in bold
and I'm not telling you
anything you don't already know
and that you talk about, Dave.
But this is the last chance.
People are walking
around with guns
in their waistbands.
They're not worried
about anything.
Because just as I unearthed,
there was a memo the DA
in Manhattan, Cy Vance,
handed out right after
one of the huge protests
which involved looting
and burning an anarchist
and all kinds of theft.
The DA comes out in his
internal memo to his staff
and he says, "We're gonna
give the protestors."
They're protesters.
Mind you, they're protestors.
- [Dave] Yeah, protestors.
- "Give them ACDs or dismissals.
But if any of those protestors
have any information
about police misbehaving
in their arrests or
mishandling them,
we will take those cases
and prosecute them.
So let the protestors go and
turn the tables on the cops."
Really?
Two cops in Compton.
You know, I mean I'm sick.
I'm sick.
People laughing.
A woman shot through the jaw
trying to say what
her number is.
This is not America.
- How worried are you that
the state of the system
because of everything that
you just described there
that in a certain way it
almost has to get worse
before it can get better
that you can't get a reset
when you have so many
sort of cowardly DAs?
Now cowardly.
I don't blame a lotta
the police chiefs
or the average policeman
who's retiring early.
I don't blame him.
It's like if you're
not gonna be backed up
by your politicians,
I don't blame them.
But do you think
it has to get worse
because enough of them
will have to disappear
and maybe you have
to then vote in
completely new politicians,
most likely Republicans without
complete chaos happening,
that it can't reset otherwise?
- Well I think two things.
I think number one,
it has to get worse
and it will get worse, okay?
There's no question.
The president is not
gonna use insurrection
unless it does get worse.
He said the time is not now.
And I also think that these.
(dogs barking)
I'm so sorry.
I have a few dogs.
- [Dave] You got your own
interaction over there.
- Yeah, I'm so sorry.
But I also think that
these politicians, these
prosecutors are in.
I mean they're not gonna be
voted out for a few years.
But the money that's coming
in to support Antifa,
outside money and the
money that's coming in
to fund these people flying
from one city to another city
where they're bailed
out in one city
to then go to another city.
I mean there's big money
behind the destruction
of this country.
- All right, so let's just
hit a couple other things
that you go into in the book.
So since we've
talked about New York
and so much of your
history is in New York,
you're not a fan
of Bill de Blasio,
the mayor of New York City.
I believe you called
him Bozo de Blasio.
Are you shocked how quickly the
city has devolved under him,
even though I know you don't
agree with any of his policies
but like just the rapid rate
that so much of the city
has just turned into chaos?
- Look, the man is either
stupid, incompetent or both,
all right?
That's what I think of Bozo.
The guy is a bozo.
I mean first of all,
the fact that he would
move to defund the police.
The fact that he started
half of this police hatred
in New York, he's been very,
very much pushing that agenda.
He doesn't support the police.
And I talked to a
lotta the upper echelon
in the police department,
the top ranks there.
I mean
they cannot deal with him
and he can't deal with them.
He's never been a fan
of law enforcement.
But by not deploying police
when there was looting going on
on 5th Avenue in Manhattan.
Now I'm not saying
because you know,
they're wealthier, they
deserve protection.
I'm not saying that at all.
Because if you got a bodega
and that's all you got,
then that's your castle
and you deserve protection
'cause you're paying taxes too.
But things that are so
obvious, so apparent,
all you have to do
is deploy the police.
He didn't do it.
I mean I was told.
He told them, "You're
gonna stand down
or we're not deploying them."
The same with Macy's
in Herald Square.
They're tryin' to
start a fire in Macy's.
Why is he so happy with that?
And the dumbest thing the
man ever said when he said,
"Oh no, these are
peaceful protestors."
You're blind too?
Where he says, "We're
gonna allow them to protest
because this is a historic
moment in history."
Are you kidding?
It's a historic
moment in history.
But don't you dare go to church.
Don't youse dare have a funeral.
Don't you dare go back to work.
Don't you dare.
And then Cuomo wants to deploy,
what was it 4,000 police?
To monitor the restaurants
to make sure people
are wearing masks
when they go in the restaurants.
When you don't have police, a
woman was raped on a platform
in the middle of the day.
There were people walking
around in Manhattan,
men without their pants on
and they're drinkin'
alcohol from a paper bag,
a flask in a paper bag.
I mean the man
doesn't have a clue.
- What do you think?
What do you think he thinks?
I mean he obviously.
I don't wanna say
he obviously doesn't
wanna destroy the city.
I don't know what the guy wants.
Like what do you think he
thinks is supposed to happen
because of his policies?
- You know, I remember
he said something
that just floored me
when they said, "Mr. Mayor."
This is right in the
beginning, "Crime is going up."
And his answer was
something like,
"Well we'll hit the streets
and we'll talk about it."
Yeah, crime is gonna go
down when you talk about it.
You're about as scary
as Big Bird, you know?
I mean this guy, he's
from another time.
I don't know.
Your question really is, is
he intentionally doing it?
You know?
- Yeah.
- Does he hate New York?
Look, this guy is Wilhelm
Comrade de Blasio.
I mean the guy even
changed his name.
He's a phony, you know?
He changed his name from
Wilhelm III or whatever
and you know, I believe
he believes in communism.
I really do.
He doesn't believe
in law and order.
That's not his agenda.
I mean his wife Chirlane says
that New York would be
nirvana without the police.
I'm gonna stop right there.
- Yeah. (chuckles)
Speaking as a judge, since
you mentioned Andrew Cuomo.
Cuomo said that eating
wings is not a meal.
That doesn't count as a meal.
Is there any legal
precedent behind that?
- My god, when did he say that?
- That's what he said.
- When did he say that?
- He said it a couple weeks ago.
Because you know, what
happened was some of the bars
started opening up and
the way they got around it
was they started serving.
'Cause he said, "You
have to have a meal."
So they started serving wings
and then the governor decided
that wings are not a meal.
- What does that tell you, Dave?
It tells you that they
wanna lock us down.
That whatever excuse they
can use to prevent us
from going out is the
excuse they're gonna use.
Fear is a very big
factor in control.
And you know, I'm
seeing people now
that I haven't seen
in months, Dave.
And they're like,
"Oh yeah, you know."
They're just different.
They're afraid.
They're afraid of everything.
You know, now that
the winter's coming,
people are gonna start
you know, staying inside
and they operate on that.
And you know, Joe Biden.
This one really knocked me out.
Joe Biden and his wife Jill.
I think it was Memorial Day,
the first you know, weekend
of the summer pretty much.
And they've been in the basement
in the bunker forever, right?
And the two of them are
going to put some flowers
on one of the burial plots.
They're walkin'
together, the two of them
in black masks
from here to here.
Just the two of them.
No one's with 'em.
- [Dave] Just the two of them.
- You've been together
bunkered up for months
and now at the end of May
you're comin' out with black
masks, just the two of you?
There's no one in sight.
What does that tell you?
It's a whole mindset.
We have to be careful
and the mask is black.
- So what would you be doin'?
If you were mayor
of New York City
or you were governor of
New York at this point
with lockdowns and
everything else,
what do you think
would be a sensible way
'bout goin' about it?
- I think the
sensible thing to do
would be to meet with
the business people
to bring the businessmen
and bring law enforcement
and to have a high-level meeting
on what they need and
what we're gonna do
and how we can do it together.
And I think right now that
with the defunding of police
assuming that's
already been done,
that we've gotta
convince the police
that maybe they're
gonna have to work
with some of these
private security guards
and at least share information
on what's going on.
Because intelligence is one
of the most important things
you can have in law enforcement
and there's gotta be an
open line of communication.
People have to be
able to go to work.
Look, you don't think
we've had enough of this?
You don't think people know:
wear a mask, wash your hands,
don't touch things, wear gloves.
I mean everybody knows
what they have to do.
This is America.
This is the land of the free
and the home of the brave.
Let us out.
Don't gimme this hogwash how
you have to lock me down.
You're not lockin'
me down anymore.
You can't tell me what to do.
You can't take my gun.
You can't tell me what to say.
You can't lock me in my home.
I've had enough of all of you.
- Judge, that is absolutely
our clip for this episode.
That was the promo right there.
You just made it very
easy for my guys.
So you mention Biden there
and chapter three is
about bunker Biden.
Joking aside for a second
and even politics aside,
what do you think is going
on with him cognitively
or health-wise?
Because it seems to me.
I've been sayin'
this for a while
that the scandal is not that
something is wrong with him.
That seems obvious to everyone.
The scandal is that
there's no scandal.
The scandal is that the
media won't talk about it
when we can all see it.
Do you think that's
a fair estimation?
I mean what do you think
is really happening there?
- Oh, I think you're
absolutely on-point there.
I think the amazing part
of it is that you know,
and this speaks to the
whole issue of the media
and their complicity
with the left.
You know, I asked the
president about this
and you know, he said to me.
The president's a wise man.
He said, you know.
He said it was almost even
between Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders in that debate
and I thought so too.
When I saw it, Joe
Biden was on his game.
And I said, "What do you
think accounts for the fact
that one day he can't
finish his sentence
and I mean you just
cringe for him?
And then you know,
the next day he'll do
something with Biden.
And obviously they're
afraid to let him out.
How is this guy
gonna run the country
when he does one
appearance, no questions,
gets back in his car and goes
home for three days and rests?
He's in a presidential campaign.
I mean how's he gonna
run the country?
Who's gonna match whits
with Putin or Kim Jong-un
or what's his name, Xi Jinping?
He can't do it, he can't do it.
So what's going on with him?"
You know, people say that
there are certain medications
that you know, can
make him more lucid.
But to me, the
telltale was last night
when Kamala Harris said,
"The Harris administration
along with Joe Biden."
I said to myself,
"Jeanine, what is going
on in the back rooms?
What are they planning?
Why is it that she's
referring to herself
as the Harris administration
with Joe Biden?
Is he the entree you
know, just to get in?"
Because I can't believe
the man is capable
of running this country.
- Judge, I don't
know if you saw this.
But like literally about 15
minutes before we started this,
he flubbed it today too
and he called it the
Harris-Biden administration.
Literally, it happened like
15 minutes before we went live
or before we started recording.
- Oh my gosh.
I rest my case.
Res ispa, the thing
speaks for itself.
Res ipsa loquitur, little Latin.
- So let's back up for a second.
Because you know, Trump
and a lotta my audience,
you know a bit about
my political evolution
and that I was a Bernie
supporter and a progressive
and a lefty and
all those things.
(chuckles) You're good.
You're a pro, you're a pro.
I should be judged accordingly
for all of those things.
But I know that there's
a lot of my audience
that I would say they don't
consider themselves conservative
per se or even on the right,
but they consider
themselves what I would say
is sort of the
disaffected liberal.
And I think that is a
huge, huge amount of people
in America right now.
The liberals that
just can't believe
how bananas the left has gone.
But I think the other
piece of that is
they just find something
about Trump off-putting
whether it's the way he speaks
or the tweeting or whatever,
somethin' like that.
So since you know him
and you talked about it
a little bit already,
if you wanted people
to be more okay
that he does love this country,
that he's a decent guy.
And it took me a long time
to get there, by the way.
I think I mentioned
this on your show.
It wasn't until I
actually met him
and I had about 10
minutes to talk to him
that I felt more okay
when he literally turned
to my husband and I
and he goes, "You guys are gay?"
He goes, "That's great.
Your only problem is
you're too handsome."
And I thought this is the guy
who says everyone's a homo.
You know, they say
that he's a homophobe.
But since you know
him a little bit more,
yeah, can you just
dive into that?
- You know, Donald Trump
is not the caricature
that they make them out to be.
And you know, there are
certain little vignettes
that I remember you
know, when my kids.
We'd go, we'd fly
down to Florida.
We had a house.
And of course, he
had Mar-a-Lago.
And he would say very
quietly to his kids,
"Don't talk to her like that.
You don't talk to
your sister like that.
him like that."
Never raised his voice.
You know, he was always serious.
And then when he got
a little more upset,
it would be no emotion.
"You just lost your allowance.
Keep it up, keep it up."
He was always attentive
to their behavior
and how they acted
toward each other.
And I'll never forget it was
toward the beginning of school.
No, the second semester I guess.
And he said, "When we
land, we're goin' to Kmart
to get our school supplies,"
he said to the kids.
And I'm like, "Donald
Trump goes to Kmart?
Wow."
(Dave chuckling)
When we would walk down
the street in Manhattan,
we went out with him a lot.
He was always kind to me.
He would say to people, "You
know, this Jeanine Pirro.
She's the DA you know,
from Westchester."
And I was always on
television for something.
And he was always more
you know, he was beholding
and try and get people
to recognize you instead of him.
Whenever he saw a cop,
whenever he saw a construction
worker or a hard hat
and they were all
enamored with him.
They were like, "Oh, hi."
They didn't have phone
cameras maybe back then.
But they say, "Can
I shake your hand?"
He would absolutely do it.
Whenever we'd go
into a restaurant
and have dinner or something,
he'd march right
into that kitchen
and take care of
everybody in the kitchen.
He is a good, generous man
and his kids are a
testament to the success
that he instilled in them.
Every one of them.
I mean those kids are smart.
They're successful.
They're brilliant,
they really are.
And as a human being you know,
you go through tough periods
in your life or your career.
He was always there for me or
you know, for my then-husband.
He was always there.
Always.
Generous in spirit,
loved his brother Robert.
I was at the White
House for the wake.
Was very, very sad about that.
Very family-oriented day.
They were always together.
He was with his sisters and
his brother and never drank.
And I remember when
I interviewed him
in 2016 right before
he ran,
there was talk of him
running and I said,
"You wanna tell people
you don't drink."
He said, "No, I don't drink.
Never had a drink."
And people were floored by that,
but I've seen him in all
hours of the day and night.
Would go Mar-a-Lago.
Everybody'd be you know,
half in the bag, not Donald.
Not Donald.
I love the guy.
He's a wonderful, wonderful
man and he loves his country.
And you know what?
I don't know anyone, Dave,
who could take the assaults
that he's taken on a daily basis
and survive them.
The guy looks better than ever.
Usually after four
years, you're exhausted.
He's rarin' to go.
- No, I know.
He's more bronze than usual now.
It must be 'cause of
peace in the Middle East.
It made him bronzer
or something.
But speakin' of the
human side of things,
I've had a bunch of
the Fox hosts on.
And you know, you guys all
just get endlessly trashed
in the media and you get
the Media Matters boycotts
and they go for your sponsors
and all of that stuff.
And I don't know how comfortable
you'll be talking about this,
but you did mention to me
once how it can take a toll
you know, when
you're in your town
and, "Oh, there's Judge Jeanine.
She's on Fox,"
and just dealin' with
some of that kinda hate
and yet you always have
a smile on your face.
I mean what's that like?
You live in New York,
you're a public person
and you gotta deal with
some pretty hateful stuff.
- Yeah, I do.
I do.
But you see, the
difference for me
is I ran for office five times.
I am hardened with steel
and I'm used to it.
I mean they used to
boycott for this or that
or I'd prosecuted a case,
they didn't like it, you know?
You know what?
I really don't care.
If you care enough that
you're thinking about
changing your mind,
then care and change your mind.
But if you believe that
what you're doing is right,
I don't give it
a second thought.
But what I am amazed at or with
is the fact that people
on the left dropped me
you know, when
Trump got elected.
My friends dropped me.
And I was like, "But I
would never drop you."
You know, I just wouldn't.
It all started you
know, we all got dropped
and I found that hurt.
That hurt.
- I know the feelin'.
- It hurt.
And you know, when
you try you know,
to not maybe sound as crazy
and then you just say,
"You know what?
I am who I am."
It's a short visit here, Dave.
All of us are here
for a short time.
And if you can't be who you are
and if you don't
know who you are,
then you better you know,
reintroduce yourself to
yourself and get movin'.
So I have no regrets
and I also don't worry
about those people
and I also am a gun owner.
I have six guns.
- As you know I am
a new gun owner,
so we share some
things in common.
So you end the book fittingly
with a closing statement,
so I feel that we should
end this interview
with a closing statement.
I mean if someone
picks up your book
and we're six weeks now roughly.
But when the book comes
out about five weeks
before the election,
what is it that you
want them to take
more than anything
else from the book?
- I want people
to recognize that
it's not just about the lies.
I mean I identify the lies
and I go through the lies.
But the most important
thing for them to understand
is that there's a quote
from Abraham Lincoln
from his speech at lyceum
where he talks about the
destruction of this country
will not come from
a foreign source.
It will come from within
and that's what we're
facing right now.
We're facing an absolute
destruction of
America as we know it
from forces within America
and we can't let that happen.
We can't forget who we are,
how free we are
and we can't not
protect Americans
and our families
and our businesses.
You know, we were happy.
We really were.
I mean some people
are just miserable.
But this is really
the land of the free
and the home of the brave
and we need to
continue to be that.
I don't need anyone to tell me
that America was never so
great or America sucks.
You know, if you
don't like America,
well then don't
live here, you know?
But we can always make changes.
Evolution is part of who we are,
but I love this country
and Donald Trump does too
and I know that.
- Judge, I was originally
gonna end this interview
by inviting myself to your house
so that I could have like
spaghetti and meatballs
or your famous lasagna.
But now that I know
you're Lebanese,
it's gonna be tabbouleh
and some baba ganoush.
What's your specialty?
- I make something
called sheikh el mahshi
which is eggplant with meat
and you know, some
little nuts in 'em.
It's delicious.
And whatever you like,
I can cook all of it.
I love it.
Shish kabob, what do you like?
What's your pleasure?
You're from California.
Yeah, I know what
you would like.
I would make you like salmon
and chicken on a shish kabob
with peppers and onions and
tomatoes, all that stuff.
That'd be good.
- You see how I just
invited myself over
and you laid out
the menu for me.
Pretty good, huh?
- I love to cook.
There's a mother
in me, you know?
I beg my kids.
I'd say, "Come home, guys.
Mom's cooking."
They're like, "Yay,
she's cooking."
Thank you, Dave.
- Judge, Judge.
I appreciate your friendship
and I hope people got to see
in a little bit
of a new way here.
The book is "Don't Lie to Me".
We're gonna link to it in
the YouTube description
and hopefully we will do this
in person one of these days.
- Soon.
- Yeah.
Thank you, Dave.
And good luck to you
and it was a pleasure.
Thank you.
- If you're lookin' for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.